iosil 29 ans un athlète de haut niveau
dans les sous bois
jour après jour ils enchaînent les
foules et 140 km par semaine pour rester
au niveau un cadre d'entraînements
idyllique un grand bonheur de quoi ici
c'est vraiment une explosion de sens
objectif c'est vraiment un plaisir de
courir dans dans ces bois quand yosi ne
court pas dans les allées de ce parc de
55 hectares il s'entraîne aussi sur son
tapis installés dans les écuries
un tapis à l'origine de sa présence au
château le 16 mars le confinement est
décrété il s'en procure un pour
continuer à s'entraîner mais le jeune
athlète se heurte à une difficulté
hélas il n'a pas pu rentrer dans mon
appartement
la porte d'entrée dans un peu trop
étroite pour le faire entrer
donc je me suis dis où je pourrais
essayer de mettre ce tapis roulant et de
courir durant ce confinement et c'est là
que je me suis proposé que j'ai demandé
à lui à perdre le brun le propriétaire
de ce lieu de m'accueillir afin de
pouvoir m'entraîner dans ses dires au
château la présence de yosi permet
d'apporter un peu de vie et de réfléchir
à l'après confinement iosis et un
encadrement professionnel
c'était une vision du sport une vision
du bien-être il nous permet pour la
presse on espère de présenter un projet
concret quand le site sera rouvert pour
que tout le monde puisse venir
j'ai la possibilité effectivement de
courir tous les jours ce qui n'est pas
le cas de tout le monde je peux courir
deux fois par jour ce qui n'est pas le
cas de tout le monde ok fectivement
c'est c'est un luxe que d'autres n'ont
pas j'en suis clairement conscient le
confinement au château de la
bourdaisière va donc se prolonger pour
yosi jusqu'au 11 mai minimum ensuite il
retrouvera sa piste d'entraînement
habituel puis la compétition à la fin de
l'été